this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode jonathan's taking another
look at the vietnam era weaponry of
rising storm 2 vietnam a game that you
really like the look of the last time
around before i forget to mention it i
feel the need to uh
comment on the white gloves that we see
in the player character in a couple of
these clips i gather that's from from
some sort of dlc but it made me chuckle
as somebody who wears white cotton
gloves quite a bit
if you want to see our previous episode
on rising storm 2 vietnam make sure to
go check it out we've got a handy link
down in the description of this video
but make sure to watch this episode as
well yeah and of course while you're
down there make sure to subscribe as
well as we've got tons of content just
like this on the channel including
loadout a show where we take a look at
the history and impact of some of the
most iconic weapons in gaming from the
shotgun and m1 garand all the way
through to the desert eagle and the
minigun we collaborated with jonathan on
loadout 2 so he'll be making a fair few
appearances on that show as well right
let's take a look at the guns of rising
storm 2 vietnam
now this is a really
fun one for me because i am actually to
my knowledge
never looks at our k50 submachine guns
now this is a north vietnam
north vietnamese licensed copy of the uh
ppsh or papashar whichever
41 soviet submachine gun it's
really quite crude um i don't know how
well you'll be able to see that on
camera
but it it it definitely looks more like
sort of bent and hammered steel
it doesn't have the
iconic wooden shotgun type stock of the
ppsh it has a sort of
welded together very heavy gauge sheet
steel lower receiver and it makes the
thing really quite heavy and the rate of
fire is preserved from the ppsh so it's
pretty much as blistering as you see in
the game there a good 700 rounds per
minute plus i i think it's probably a
bit more than that so we've got only say
only 35 rounds in the magazine but sort
of 7 800 rounds per minute that that
goes quickly unlike the ppsh famous for
its 71 round drum magazine this this
variant if you like or derivative does
not have that capability they were not
made they were not acquired and
when you slide the stock shut
you can sort of see why because it
prevents
the drum the curve of the drum would be
would be in the way
shotguns um what we've got there is the
ithaca model 37 which is a pretty iconic
vietnam
shotgun
so much so that james cameron put it in
aliens which is famously a bit of a
vietnam allegory in space it's subtext
but it's relatively in your face subtext
and so for hicks's shotgun they
literally give him an antique a family
heirloom as he puts it which is um the
vietnam vintage ithaca
i'd like to keep this handy
for close encounters the only one i
think that we have in the collection is
this
very sporting
trim version of the ithaca so it's it's
different in various details i say
sporting it this is actually marketed as
a police variant but this one is
engraved
with some relatively crude
headless ducks which is a little
disturbing i'm not really sure why the
ducks are headless and flying through
the air
um i don't think engraving on
budget not budget shockers but
mainstream shotguns is quite what it was
in previous decades i think the the
probably the main
identifier of the ithaca is the lack of
an ejection port on the side you can't
see the bolt
that all happens
underneath by vietnam we had had several
attempts at bayonet equipped shotguns
going back to the 1897 trench gun of the
first world war basically the same idea
but done on what was then in the
inventory so the ithaca 37
with a perforated heat shield on it so
you don't burn your hands while you're
grasping the barrel to stab somebody in
the face and amount for the i believe it
was still the model 1917 bayonet same as
it was previously and it's one of those
conflicts where something like that sort
of worked so any sort of jungle warfare
a shotgun is going to be a lot more
useful than it would be in a lot of
other conditions of course it does still
limit you as you'll no doubt find out
playing the game if the only weapon
you've got is something that's very good
up to maybe 50 meters and not very good
beyond it you are a little bit limited
in what you can do but that's the whole
point of having a squad of other
soldiers equipped with a variety of
weapons and for for up close and
personal you can't beat a pump action
we are taking delta
the m14 is a quite a fascinating rifle
in many ways it's not very remarkable it
was a very conservative take on a future
infantry rifle there were many more
advanced designs around at the time in
the 50s when it was being adopted and
it's the culmination of a long torturous
story that's actually in my my new book
uh about british bullpups because
britain was trying to foist its very
high tech fully automatic optically
sighted bullpup assault rifle on its
allies including america and they
weren't having it they went
full conservative kind of let's stay
with what we know and they basically
slapped a box magazine and an improved
gas system on the m1 garand it wasn't
really enough of an improvement and
although it the m14 had a relative
reputation for reliability and being a
sort of man stopper it
lasted only seven years in uh us army
servers which i think is the shortest
lived service rifle in u.s
history a very interesting rifle maybe
not the best for vietnam but i'm not
going to second-guess veterans that were
there and actually used it
we go from the m14 to its descendant i
suppose immediate descendant the the m21
sniper rifle or at this stage the xn x
of course meaning experimental uh this
is a real thing this this was in use in
the late 60s as one of the a number of
weapons that were effectively field
trialled the interesting thing
for me here is the uh the suppressor um
we have both versions in the game
suppressed and unsuppressed and we see
the the player is operating the bolt
might might surprise some people but if
you played the game or you know a bit
about how this works
subsonic ammunition
depending on the type of weapon does not
generate sufficient pressure to cycle
the action of the weapon so it's it
turns you by using reduced power
ammunition to get a lower report so the
suppressor can suppress it more
effectively you don't get the the crack
of the bullet as it goes through the air
you lose um the ability to fire rapid
follow-up shots so you're going back in
time in terms of your rifle's capability
for as long as you're using the
suppressor and the subsonic ammunition
now what a lot of games get wrong is
putting a suppressor on the weapon does
not magically well in a couple of cases
it does but generally it does not
magically reduce the velocity of the
bullet and therefore does not make the
ammunition subsonic what generally
happens certainly in this case you would
need special subsonic ammunition to get
that extra quiet effect where the enemy
doesn't get the crack of the bullet
isn't alerted to where they're getting
shot at from um now in this game this
game gets around that gameplay
compromise of when you put the
suppressor on your ammo go subsonic by
having the two different variants so
you've either got the suppressor and
you're loading subsonic ammo or you've
not got the suppressor and you're
loading supersonic ammo subsonic
ammunition did make it to vietnam by at
least one account from a veteran but
allegedly
the sort of quality control on the
amount of powder in the cases was not
great and one in four cartridges was
still making a supersonic crack so those
probably would cycle the action but
you'd lose your otherwise very quiet but
still quite powerful
rifle
the good old mosin the three-line rifle
as it was known in russia was in vietnam
as it has been in so many conflicts as a
bit of a hand-me-down from an earlier
era but um if you could find a good one
that wasn't
shot out and was accurate when it was
made this was the key thing with the
mosin rifles it could be a very capable
accurate sniper rifle but many of them
were made hastily and not particularly
well
and i'm not fit to be sniper rifle but
the ones that are shoot well
and would serve you well the interesting
thing about this implementation we've
got a i think it was a pu scope on there
is that has enough well has a downside
of the height over bore so that your
point of aim point of impact has to be
factored in
but it means that you can see
under the scope body
the iron sights and you can just use the
iron sights for closer up
work that said the scope mount kind of
obstructs your field of view anyway so
how useful that is before it depends on
the situation and how good a shooter you
were
[Music]
this is not as instant as an m16 or an
ak or an m60 as a vietnam firearm but if
you're australian or you know their
involvement it pretty much is this is of
course the owen gun which is perhaps
best thought of as
a parallel universe stem gun it's a
similar design remit something to to
fire a pistol cartridge relatively
rapidly
very cheaply probably most notable for
that top-mounted magazine which we see
being flipped over and pulled out the
top of the gun in the reload animation
so this is a
lieutenant evelyn owen so it's a bit of
a home brew this is one where a serving
soldier or officer in this case came up
with his own design and the military
procurement authorities were
sufficiently impressed that they
trialled it and actually adopted it
although i mentioned the sten gun um the
owen is much more of an original design
it is not the austen uh it's important
to distinguish the two so the owen gun
is the more indigenous design if you
like the osten is is the australian take
using the available manufacturing
methods and skills on the stem gun so
it's the stem gun adapted to australian
indus industry the owen is better
thought of because of its because it is
more original i think um it's become the
more iconic
of the two and it's the one that you you
tend to encounter in the context of
the aussies in vietnam
the rpd uh designed as part of a new
system of small arms that included the
sks and this was the squad support
weapon so using the same intermediate
power 7.62 by 39 millimeter cartridge
found to be
a bit lacking and ultimately
sort of phased out in favor of the much
better pk as a sort of squad level belt
fed machine gun but as with a lot of
soviet weapons lots were already made
it functioned fine for the most part so
they found their way into other trouble
spots including vietnam and that's why
it makes sense here
before i forget to mention it i feel the
need to
comment on the
white gloves that we see
in the player character in a couple of
these clips i gather that's from from
some sort of dlc but it made me chuckle
uh somebody who wears white cotton
gloves quite a bit anyway
what those gloves are holding is the sks
siminov carbine why have a
semi-automatic
weapon in the same caliber as the ak so
the answer is
that the the immediate need was for a
self-loading rifle but it had already
been identified that the reduced power
cartridge was the way to go and it
already identified that
you would need an assault rifle what was
less clear in 1945 was that the assault
rifle could in fact replace every
rifle in the infantry squad the plan in
45 with this new intermediate cartridge
was to leverage the benefits of low
recoil therefore better semi-automatic
accuracy the ak was going to be for
specialist
troops and so you'd have a two-tier
system you'd have the assault rifle for
those that needed automatic fire and
you'd have the sks as your standard
infantry rifle but of course from 1949
onwards when the ak has been introduced
very quickly it's clear that the ak is
the way to go it does everything the sks
does and more and especially for soviet
doctrine which called for automatic
burst fire as the default way to fire
your rifle in most situations it made
sense to bim the sks and so it became a
reserved weapon and
hundreds of thousands of them found
their way around the world the sks has
its own interesting story behind it and
there were lots of them in vietnam
if you'd like to support the work that
we do here at the royal armouries both
with gamespot and over on our own
channel have a look at the video
description we have a couple of links
for you in there otherwise i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you